Speaker 1: So Donald Trump's niece, Mary Trump,
is again weighing in on what she believes is
the growing fear in her uncle, Donald Trump, of
the walls closing in around him and criminality
enveloping him and possibly leading to charges.
And we're going to look at a clip of her appearing
on I believe it's MSNBC to talk about this. And I
do find it interesting. But at the same time and
if I'm wrong, please tell me. I appreciate the
perspective of someone from Trump's family and
when she first emerged from the shadows, it was
particularly interesting. But now I'm actually
wondering what Mary Trump really knows about
what's going on right now with Donald Trump,
because as far as I know, she has no contact with
him or that side of the family whatsoever. So
let's take a listen. This is interesting and
it may well be what Donald Trump is feeling,
but it may be just as speculative as what I can
deduce Trump might be feeling from his posts on
social more than any personal
knowledge. Let's take a look.
Speaker 2: Joining me now is Donald Trump's niece,
Mary Trump. She's the author of Too Much and
Never Enough. Mary, good morning. Always
good to see you. Listen, by your training,
you are a psychologist and you also know someone.
You are someone who knows Trump very well. What
do you think is going through his mind right now?
Because there's an incredibly getting even larger
amount of damning testimony that's coming out.
And noticeably, he did not attack Pat Cipollone
before Cipollone. He testified
before the one six committee.
Speaker 3: Yeah. Good morning, Kitty. I
think Neal Katyal summed it up quite nicely.
Speaker 2: You know, to say
that Donald is terrified is.
Speaker 3: Accurate and also an
understatement. I think this might be
the first time in his entire life.
Speaker 2: That even he.
Speaker 3: Can deny the walls
may indeed be closing in.
Speaker 2: The amount of evidence that
we've seen coming out of these committee
hearings is overwhelming. But even more.
Speaker 3: Troubling for him is the
witnesses now coming forward.
Speaker 1: So, I mean, like,
it's interesting, but it has a sort of like
daytime TV feel thing to it rather than real
journalism because Mary Trump has no contact
with Trump and she hasn't for a long time. And
let's imagine she's right about Trump's fears and
state of mind right now, which she may well be.
It's possible to come to that same conclusion
from what's available publicly. In fact, I have
come to the same conclusion. So that's one piece
of it. And the continued Mary Trump interviews,
on the other hand, you know, when it comes to
accountability, accountability has to be real.
It can't just be discussed. It can't just be well,
accountability is all these people made to look
really guilty during their testimony. Okay, that's
fine. But it's got to lead to something. And maybe
if Trump is held accountable at some point, we
can sort of define a line that can't be crossed,
and it would be quite a low bar. But if we can't
even do that, then this is just going to happen
again. And we've talked before about how right
now, because there have been no real consequences
for Donald Trump to everything that he did.
And I won't give you the full list, because
I'm sure at this point you're sick of hearing
it. It's not evident that you can't cross the
lines. We're not really a democracy in the sense
of checks and balances, one person, one vote, etc.
If you can have checks and balances that don't
actually keep anyone in check and balanced
against their fascistic tendencies and we don't
know what's taking so long now. To some degree,
it takes a while to build cases, and
if there are indictments from DOJ,
it may take some time. But for now it is not
clear that we even have an infrastructure
willing and able to assign consequences and
repercussions for what has taken place. So
interesting to hear from Mary Trump. I don't
really know that at this point. She really
knows any more than any of us do because of how
long she hasn't been in touch with Donald Trump